[Musique]
jean bertin avait déposé en 20 ans le
total de 3000 brevets d'invention son
imagination débordante touché la
dissipation du brouillard sur les
aéroports
l'effeuilleuse d'artichaut les
silencieux pour avions mais le procédé
qui l'avait fait connaître au grand
public reposait sur l'utilisation du
coussin d'air l'ancien responsable des
réacteurs de la snecma pensais tout
simplement avoir découvert la technique
qui succéderait à la roue plusieurs fois
millénaire son principe faire reposer le
poids de l'engin de transport sur
l'ensemble de la surface par des jets
d'air assurant une portance parfaite
il ne restait plus qu'à assurer la
mobilité de l'appareil par ellis ou
turbine le système bertin du coussin
d'air connaît un certain succès sur mer
c'est le na'vi plane ou hovercraft par
contre malgré des années d'essais malgré
un encouragement de l'aménagement du
territoire à l'origine
l'aérotrain systèmes urbains ou
intervilles guidé par un rail de béton
ne plus dépasser le stade du prototype
un temps prévu sur le parcours la
défense cergy pontoise
il fut abandonné par l'état l'an dernier
père du projet cerveau qui vivait avec
ses inventions jean bertin ne s'était
jamais vraiment remis de ce coup
terrible il laissera le souvenir rare
d'un technicien qui essayait de
convaincre par le coeur une question est
posée à présent l'aérotrain lui
survivra-t-il ou rejoindre at il comme
d'autres innovations françaises au cours
des temps le musée des occasions perdues
[Musique]